it's me
santa claus or should i say
fresh claws oh
thank you for having me in the rt studio
to host rt essentials today i'm going to
go over notable and classic christmas
films as recommended by the good people
of the rotten tomatoes team
but with a twist you see the films on
today's show are all
naughty
excuse rotten
rotten apologies i got my list mixed up
there happy holidays
let's commence the rt essentials rotten
christmas movies episode i'm sorry
i'm sorry what is it we actually have a
last minute change here uh it seems that
they want your uh your brother to summon
for the episode
where is he
he's here
oh son of a
are you sure about this i mean i i get
the theme and all but it just he is the
worst you know it's
not easy to get a ride here from the
north pole
you you could have booked maul santa for
that
donner get the keys hey bye bro don't
let blitzen's antlers hit you on the way
out
okay where do i look hey right here look
it's a camera now what's up everyone i
guess you can call me rotten claws for
this whatever makes you feel better now
look these movies yeah sure once upon a
time critics thought they sucked but i'm
here to tell you that subjectivity is
everything and that i am i mean these
christmas movies are great and though
they're rotten they are christmas movies
nonetheless and they can 100 provide the
same love care
warmth
health benefits as any of the fresh
christmas movies out there all right
i mean not everyone can get a mark twain
award-winning snl star in tights and the
director of iron man okay on with the
list
home alone two i know i know who knew
rotten i mean
get down on your knees and tell me you
love me
on your knees
i love you
director chris columbus originally
wanted to make two sequels to home alone
and shoot them back to back before star
mccully culkin aged out of the role but
20th century fox executives said no
concerned about how much it would cost
they probably felt pretty smart after
lost in new york opened to a critical
drubbing it's got a low 33 percent
tomato meter score but in the end it may
very well have been the wrong call by
the time home alone 3 eventually did hit
theaters in 1997 with the new lead
character audiences have largely lost
interest and the movie flopped
[Music]
hold it right there
this is the concierge sir
i knew it was you i could smell you
getting off the elevator
this scene in particular revisits a
favorite gag from the first film in
which kevin mcallister used a fake
gangster film called angels with filthy
souls to trick harry and marv the iconic
wet bandits into believing they were in
the house with him this time he screens
that movie's even more fake sequel
obviously titled angels with even
filthier souls don't give me that you've
been spooking with everybody
snuffy ale leo little moe with the gimpy
leg
cheeks bony bob cliff
no
it's a lie
these quick sequences of course parody a
very real 1938 gangster movie called
angels with dirty faces starring the
great james cagney and the fake movies
have remained part of the pop culture
lexicon ever since they can be seen in
the background in the 2019 video game
adaptation pokemon detective pikachu hey
you quick look up the score of pokemon
detective pikachu come on
fresh
oh yes yes 68
face it some of you thought that was a
rotten movie don't lie to me you thought
it was rotten i love you
maybe i'm off my hinges
but i believe you that's why i'm gonna
let you go
and yes that is tim curry as the hotel
concierge he's not identified by name in
the film but in the script he was known
as mr hector i can't believe they left
that on the cutting room floor thank
goodness we finally get to tell the
world am i right
three
merry christmas you filthy animal
and a happy new year
[Music]
four christmases
[Music]
four christmases was not a hit with
viewers or critics when it first entered
theaters in 2008 coming in with just 25
on the tomato meter even today it's only
earned a marginally better 47 from
audiences nonetheless the story about
coming unglued during stress-filled
family gatherings a constant theme on
this list has made the caustic comedy a
perennial favorite amongst christmas
movie fans how about now worse it's
worse
take the damn thing down i can do better
with my rabbit ears all right
it's honestly kind of shocking the film
scored so low with such an all-star cast
all four actors who play vince vaughn
and reese witherspoon's character's
parents robert duvall [ __ ] spacek john
boyne and mary steenburgen are oscar
winners and get this three of the film
stars want oscars specifically for
playing country western singers wait you
don't think i can name them of course i
can reese witherspoon and walk the line
robert duvall and tender mercies and
[ __ ] spacek in the coal miner's
daughter
boom
i don't even want a fancy satellite i
don't want any kind of satellite not a
satellite genius it's a satellite dish
[Music]
though he was working with a cast of
veterans this was director seth gordon's
scripted feature debut he got the gig
based on his competitive video game
documentary the king of kong a fistful
of quarters which caught vince vaughn's
attention
[Music]
the house in this scene by the way was
built specifically for the production in
the shadow hills neighborhood outside of
los angeles so the roof could be
reinforced to support the weight of not
just these actors but an entire camera
crew that's a lot of gear but they
probably also had too much eggnog and
sugar cookies or if you party with me
during christmas eve that's what we call
egg stream nog and sugar
cookies
don't worry i'll i'll give you the
recipe
[Music]
the polar express
that brings us to director robert
zemeckis's animated storybook adaptation
the polar express first released in
2004. critics at the time knocked the
animation particularly on the human
characters which made them look and i
quote uncanny dead-eyed and like zombies
again if you party with me
you'll look like that christmas morning
nonetheless this adventure-filled
journey to the north pole still managed
to 56 on the tomato meter and a 63 with
audiences who were charmed despite the
you know dead eyes the film is based on
an illustrated children's book by chris
van alsberg the same author whose work
inspired jumanji it was also the very
first animated film made entirely using
the motion capture process in which live
actors record their roles and then these
performances are animated into the film
get us the blazers out of here
the technique never really took off in
animation though zamekas reused the
process for his christmas carol
adaptation with jim carrey but it has
remained very common in live action
films that have computer animated
characters the technique allows star tom
hanks to play five different characters
in the film the main hero as an adult
the hero's dad the train conductor we
see here a hobo and santa claus
personally i consider that list an order
of importance
when two of his characters interacted in
the film hanks would record one roll
with a stand-in and then switch off on
set
that's daryl sabara from the spy kids
film voicing the main boy character here
but he didn't do the actual motion
capture that was actually done by a 12
year old pre-hunger games josh
hutcherson so wow the odds really were
in his favor thank you
oh thank you
i can't believe you got my ticket
did someone say they found the ticket
well in that case
tickets please
[Music]
the santa claus 2.
[Music]
can i help you
the second film in the santa claus
franchise massively expanded on the
scale and scope of the first movie
tripling the budget and digging deeper
into the series fanciful world of
mythological characters sadly it was not
as warmly embraced by critics or
audiences pulling in less money at the
box office and earning just a 56 score
from critics and an even lower 42 from
audiences
[Music]
[Music]
the film was the debut of director
michael lembeck who had worked on tv for
many years leading up to this
interestingly this film features the
tooth fairy in a relatively small
supporting role and lembek would later
direct the 2010 film wait for it tooth
fairy which features the same character
and a markedly similar plot yes it's
about the rock having to take over the
job of the tooth fairy
maybe they're not so similar
the santa claus series are the films
that made a movie star out of tim allen
who up to this point was mostly known
for home improvement and stand-up comedy
but he wasn't the studio's first choice
when casting santa claus part one they'd
already talked to tom selleck tom hanks
chevy chase and bill murray before
meeting with allen one year after that
first santa claus film allen debuted as
the voice of buzz lightyear in the first
pixar toy story movie which cemented him
as a film comedy superstar in this scene
he actually references the buzz
lightyear role when the artificial toy
santa tells scott calvin you are a sad
strange little man
to corporate synergy and beyond
[Music]
[Music]
jingle all the way
no film on this list has a wider golf
between its public esteem and its tomato
meter score than jingle all the way a
beloved nostalgic classic with an
unthinkably paltry 15
on the tomato meter critics may have
found the arnold schwarzenegger family
comedy shrill and uneven but audiences
just want to see two things turbo man
and for you to put the cookie down the
north pole them are fighting words
partner put them up all relax buddy
i'm not about to hit a santa claus come
on come on hoodie
this scene features jim belushi as one
of the crooked santas
tell me about it
the two actors had previously shared the
screen in a very different film 1988's
red heat belushi also came to set
prepared to play santa he earned money
during college by assuming the role of
kris kringle with private parties and
events and had even once been the santa
for a stage christmas concert yeah if
you want a guy who's gonna relentlessly
prep for any role no matter how small
you call james belushi that's
established hollywood wisdom
and uh you know it's only a matter of
time before
someone plays me daniel day lewis
perhaps
[Applause]
i'm gonna deck your halls bub
though the film was written by randy
cornfield it was also partly inspired by
a real experience producer chris
columbus had while trying to buy a buzz
lightyear doll for christmas he said
it's almost like searching for a
christmas eve holy grail i couldn't find
it anywhere that was when i came to
understand the universality of this
situation who's gonna be next
[Applause]
that highly coveted turbo man doll was
designed by tim flattery an expert who
had previously created characters for
the batman and mighty morphin power
rangers tv series he made the toy first
and then all the marketing and costumes
were designed based around that
[Music]
the holiday
hold please
i can't believe that you have had sex
with the woman staying in my house
he told you that
oh my god oh my god oh my god i thought
i was talking to graham could you just
hold please i'm
terribly sorry
audiences embraced writer director nancy
myers 2006 house swapping romantic
comedy even if it left some critics a
little cold it's sitting on a massive 80
audience score even if it only has a 50
on the tomato meter oh amanda's
next-door neighbor oh by the way you
should pop over and meet her
yeah i have actually oh bugger
call waiting can you hold for a sec hold
on i really want to talk to you sure
hello iris hi it's amanda the characters
in the movie exchange houses using a
real website called
homeexchange.com that actually still
exists to this day so if you are british
but nonetheless want to fall in love
with jack black
i don't know maybe here's your chance my
brother wants to know how you are can
you tell him that i'm good and that i'm
just taking charlie for a walk in the
village um what's he been up to did he
say
i'm not sure do you want me to ask him
uh sure
how please myers said she wrote the film
with all four leads in mind but black
took some convincing before he was
willing to do a romantic comedy
well as the romantic lead his big break
in films was in a rom-com high fidelity
but in the wacky friend role
i can't believe you've had sex with
amanda the one thing she asked me was
are there any men in your town and i
assured her that they were not and then
you meet her and immediately get into
her knickers
still me
myers asked jude law to base his
performance around clark gable and
apparently gave him a bunch of gable
films to take home and study one more
fun tidbit on jude law in the film his
sister's name is iris which is actually
the name of his daughter in real life ah
is that cute or is it just a coincidence
i'm gonna go with cute what are you up
to this christmas eve not much um but in
a little bit i was gonna go down to the
video shop and get the next movie on
arthur's list do you want some company
love some
reindeer games
the 2000 action crime film reindeer
games was the final movie directed by
filmmaking icon john frankenheimer the
visionary behind classics like seconds
seven days in may the manchurian
candidate and ronan nonetheless it had a
fairly troubled journey to the big
screen which helps to explain the paltry
25 tomato meter score and the only
slightly improved 27 percent rating from
audiences
the film was supposed to open around
christmas 1999 but got pushed back to
february of 2000 after a string of
disappointing test screenings led to
reshoots studio executives also made
frankenheimer cut 20 minutes from the
film that he felt made it less sexy and
ultimately satisfying a director's cut
was released years later on dvd
do what my friends say they're a little
bit
[Music]
disturbed
[Music]
co-star charlize theron baron the ron
i like her has also been tough on the
movie calling it her least favorite film
from her entire filmography she said she
ultimately did the movie just as an
excuse to work with john frankenheimer
ben affleck still took his role
seriously he actually trained with a
real reformed criminal to learn how to
hotwire vehicles for his role as a
professional car thief the film's title
is of course a reference to rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer the most overplayed
christmas tune ever and it's also a nod
to affleck's character because his name
is rudy and his cellmate who came up
with the entire casino robbery plan is
nick
get it
like saint nick coming up with a toy
delivery plan and then rudolph helps him
carry it out right
forget about him
there's no future for people like you
and me nick
in europe the film was actually released
as deception because the song and
animated special rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer are a lot less popular there
thank goodness and there was concern
that no one was going to get the
reference
[Music]
dr seuss's how the grinch stole
christmas
doubt
another unmistakable sign of the heavy
babies
no
you're
dead
i don't want to blow your mind but did
you know that the grinch wasn't
originally green when he was first
conceived by dr seuss the character
first appeared in a 32 line illustrated
poem called the who bub and the grinch
which was published in the may
1955 edition of red book magazine with
just black and white illustrations
even the dr seuss book how the grinch
stole christmas mostly features black
and white drawings with occasional
dashes of red and pink
no the grinch wasn't green until chuck
jones designed him that way for the
iconic 1966 animated tv special the
iconic animator behind your favorite
coyote and roadrunner shorts said he
based the color on a very unappealing
rental car he was once given how dare
you enter the glitches now
the impedance the audacity it took jim
carrey about three hours each day to put
on all the heavy makeup and prosthetics
required to be the grinch including the
extremely uncomfortable frisbee-like
contact lenses that made the ghoulish
character's eyes pop
the very first time they put the full
outfit on carrie it took an excruciating
eight and a half hours to complete the
process
this took four minutes i'm not scared
denial is to be expected in the face of
pure evil
i don't think so carrie later compared
it to being buried alive and he trained
using the same endurance techniques cia
operatives used to prepare for
potentially being tortured at several
points he said he nearly walked off the
project due to the extreme discomfort of
wearing the costume but hey it was all
worth it i guess
i mean it only has a 49 on the tomato
meter but a lot of you kids who grew up
with it seem to love it so what the hell
do they know
that's taylor momsen by the way as young
cindy lou who in her first major screen
role she went on to co-star and gossip
girl and now records music with the rock
band the pretty reckless like everyone
who played who's in this movie she had
to go to extensive whose school to learn
how the characters would act and move
around but how did the teachers know
that's my who teaches the teachers in
that
scenario
kids today
so desensitized by movies and television
what do you want
mr grinch
i came to invite you
to be holiday cheer meister
uh
holiday who be wary
a bad mom's christmas did your mom's
do your mom's have your
hairstyle
you know
every time
i think i'm the tough one in this group
kiki
you open your mouth
and then i'm like
no
i'm doing great the sequel to bad moms
came out in 2017 just one year after the
first movie hey when you got a property
as hot as bad moms you do not mess
around
still maybe a bit of added
pre-production time would have helped to
improve the film's 32 tomato meter and
44 audience score or not well then you
need to fight her
like
physically that is correct amy
i can teach you some basic karate moves
but we all know that she's going to keep
treating you like this until you beat
the sh out of her i don't want you to
meet my mom critics aren't even the only
ones who had a rough time with a bad
mom's christmas it was widely held up as
one of the more disappointing studio
releases of 2017. in fact three new
zealand comedians did an entire podcast
goofing on it the kiwis watched this
film once a week for an entire year
that is commitment to a bit moms are so
weird
how's christmas with your mom
oh you know it's
it's okay it's okay i guess yeah i mean
my mom got her hair cut and colored
exactly like mine but i think that's
pretty normal right did your mom's
do your moms have your
hairstyle the sequel introduces
christine baranski susan sarandon and
cheryl hines as the mothers of the main
three cast members mila kunis katherine
han and kristen bell respectively
interestingly though heinz is playing
bell's mom here the actresses are only
15 years apart in real life the duo had
previously collaborated on 2009's
serious moonlight in which bell starred
and heinz directed catherine hahn
convinced sarandon to appear as her
mother by writing her a heartfelt note
which sarandon later described as a real
kiss my ass kind of letter so if you
ever have a favorite ask of susan
sarandon now you know the approach to
take you ever want me to do a favor skip
the writing give me a cookie guys are we
not taking christmas back this year
yeah
i'm asking you that seriously because i
got so wasted at the mall i can't
remember if i actually said that or if
that's just something that i'm dreaming
about right now
the ice harvest
the 2005 crime comedy the ice harvest
wasn't a huge hit with audiences or
critics despite a hefty pedigree it was
the second to last film directed by the
great harold ramus and it was co-written
by robert benton the author of classics
like the original 1970s superman and
kramer versus kramer you didn't
asphyxiate yet did you
come
then i took his gun
that's the voice of character actor mike
starr as roy the guy who's locked in the
trunk by the way he would later appear
alongside billy bob thornton again in
another crime comedy set during the
holidays 2016's bad santa too but you
probably know him as the guy from dumb
and dumber who wouldn't harry torment
with the most annoying sound in the
world remember that guy i'm gonna do the
sound i
santa would have there's no way that
this thing is gonna fit in a piece of
mercedes if it don't wanna lincoln
nah they're surprisingly spacious vic
this was actually one of the rare films
directed by rammus that he didn't have a
hand in writing himself probably because
he had the kramer vs kramer guy to do it
for him he did sneak one personal detail
in there the film strip club location is
known as the sweet cage which was a
family restaurant that rammus and his
parents used to frequent when he was a
kid
you keep that up you're gonna
spring the lock
ramus had offered the role eventually
taken by john cusack to his old friend
bill murray but the snl vet never
returned his calls the two had a falling
out while making groundhog day and
didn't ultimately reconcile until close
to the end of rammus's life in 2014. hey
roy
really
i can't wait for you to feel the icy
water seeping into this trunk
shriveling your
before you drown
almost christmas
it was gonna be disgusting i did you a
favor do me a damn favor don't burn down
the damn house
this audience favorite from 2016 comes
from writer director david e talbert who
went on to write and direct the netflix
christmas musical jingle jangle he
didn't however originally conceive of
this one as a christmas movie the film
was originally set during thanksgiving
and was even titled a myers thanksgiving
after the maine family when the studio
decided to shift the setting the title
was changed to a myers christmas and
then ultimately almost christmas i guess
they figured we didn't know who the
myers were just yet i knew it was going
to be tough
but i said surely the children she loved
so much and then they'll get her life
for
would find a way to make it work
obviously i was wrong many of the cast
members in this scene had already worked
together on other projects jb smoove and
ramadi malko co-starred in the bet
series the real husbands of hollywood
and malco and gabrielle union both
appear in the think like a man movies
2016 was also a big year for co-star
jesse usher he not only popped up in a
crucial role here but starred as will
smith's son in independence day
resurgence this was already the third
time usher had played a football player
in a movie after when the game stands
tall and level up he later went on to
star in amazon's the boys as a train who
could probably make the nfl with his
lightning speed but he's opted to go the
superhero route instead
i don't think it pays as well i'm not
the one who tried to deep fry the whole
kitchen am i no and i don't think i was
making the blackaroni and cheese over
there so i think we should just go maybe
you want some pizza and wings or
something you know i got to watch my
carbs right oh that's fine they got that
like high school cheerleader menu
man shut up
oh good right
ernest saves christmas
oh
party punch
yeah that ought to hold
critics were never fans of the earnest
films the second entry in the movie
franchise after 1987's earnest goes to
camp only scored 36 on the tomato meter
but for kids who came of age during the
earnest era the jim varney character has
remained a beloved backwoods icon of
course we're a little early so we could
help him decorate and maybe you know put
out the food little finger sandwiches
and
cheese balls and beans earnest had
originally been created by the nashville
ad agency cardin and cherry for a series
of local tv spots but he kept growing in
prominence and popularity until they
decided to put him in movies and tv
shows as well just like the geico
caveman
ho ho ho burn very close
i thought you said this vern was a
friend of yours dog verm's just like
that he'll do anything for a laugh come
on
it's santa's little party helper
this is harmony
she's been having having a tough time
helping her out you know kind of a
father image kind of thing while they
were making earnest saves christmas
varney and director john cherry were
also simultaneously producing ernest's
short-lived saturday morning sketch tv
series hey vern it's ernest though this
was the second film in the earnest
series it was actually the third movie
to feature the character who made his
screen debut in the bizarre 1985 comedy
dr otto and the riddle of the gloom beam
it's also the highest grossing earnest
movie pulling in 28 million dollars
domestically on a six million dollar
budget still it only managed to hit
number two at the box office on its
opening weekend ernest saves christmas
got beat out by a little slasher movie
starring a killer doll named chucky
called child's play
maybe you've heard of it
he got fired
and some crazy old guy stepped in for a
30 cab ride and instead of calling the
cops bobo here knocked down the meter
notably this scene is the only reference
to the vern character a mainstay of the
earnest ads and saturday morning series
even though he never actually appears on
screen in any of the movies this was
also the first movie to be shot almost
entirely in orlando florida on the still
under construction disney mgm studios
backlog
in fact the park's backlot tour ride
included a stop right here at vern's
house until 2002.
that must have been an exciting treat
you know what i mean vern
i've always wanted to do that flay
bell's tinkling in the snow
on that puppy's really stuck normally
you know burn it looks like a
transmutation of 110 in the 220.
the family stone
[Music]
the 2005 comedy the family stone fared a
bit better than most of our rotten
selections hitting 53 percent with
critics and 63 with audiences this has
got to have something to do with the
enormous cast playing the stone family
and their friends and significant others
many of whom are showcased in this very
sequence the nine castmates playing
stones spent weeks together in rehearsal
so that they could bond convincingly
they also all studied sign language
together as in the film they have a deaf
family member named thaddeus
what's so great about you guys nothing
we're just it's just that we're all
we've got we're not so great everett and
ben the two fighting brothers we see
here played by dermott mulroney and luke
wilson were originally going to be billy
crudup and johnny knoxville before they
both dropped out of the film aaron
eckart had also been considered for
mulroney's part but he was never in
young guns like dermot was
in this memorable sequence sarah jessica
parker as meredith spills a kind of
breakfast casserole all over herself
that's known as strata the shot of the
strata actually spilling all over
meredith had to be redone numerous times
from different angles and because the
stains had to match up exactly in every
shot sarah jessica parker wore this
soiled top for hours and hours on end
add this to the fact that diane keaton
to get into character was apparently
really mean to sarah jessica parker on
set and you have the makings of a
somewhat unpleasant experience however
parker waiter said she enjoyed making
the film and the chance to work with
keaton even if they didn't always get
along
last christmas
santa um i think i can take over from
there because um there's also someone
here a gentleman who requires your
specific assistance
yes you can have a look think about it
i'm gonna show you to the even bigger
nutcrackers around the corner
which brings us all the way to 2019 and
director paul feig's musical holiday
rom-com last christmas this is actually
feig's second christmas comedy following
2006's unaccompanied minors after that
film didn't receive much attention or
fanfare feig was hesitant to return to
the genre but was convinced after
reading the script
[Music]
this is a big nutcracker am i not sweet
inside there depends on how big i am
that script by the way was co-written by
emma thompson who shares the story
credit with her husband greg wives it's
the first time the duo has been credited
on a film together
though she's best known as an actress
thompson is actually an accomplished
screenwriter she wrote that 1995
adaptation of sense and sensibility in
which she also co-starred and also
scripted the nanny mcfee films and the
2016 bridget jones sequel bridget
jones's baby oh she had a baby
good
the film was inspired by the george
michael song last christmas which the
artist claimed to have ridden in about
one hour while visiting his parents
one hour what a show-off he probably
spent eight weeks on wake me up before
you go go
of all the things
in my life
this is my best thing
what is
christmas last christmas was shot almost
entirely on location in london avoiding
crowds by filming very late at night
sometimes around 2 a.m thompson herself
starred in another christmas comedy that
was also memorably shot in london 2003's
love actually to me it is perfect
actually it's i don't really like love
actually
this is why i love to come in here i
also love it that is why i have this
shop
[Music]
so what do you think are these films
genuinely rotten or are these critics
and fans just a bunch of grinches whose
hearts could stand to grow a few sizes
whether your holiday favorites feature
the griswolds or the skeletons keep it
here for lots more updates on all kinds
of movies fresh and rotten from your
friends at rotten tomatoes i'm rotten
claws and i'll see you next time
take that big bro
new star in the studio now do i see you
about payment do i invoice do i you can
email us okay yeah
this was fun yeah you want to get a bite
after this i'm pretty free
no
i'm double parked
[Music]
[Music]
you